みなさんこんにちは宮城県からまいりまし
た早坂久美子です
現在36歳です
高校まで宮城で過ごして大学から北海道に
渡ってきました
ちょうど半々の人生です
私ものすごく緊張 c なので地元の
母さんが心配だからと守りをくれたんです
これがまず手作りのものなんですけれども
スペインタイルで作ったペンダント
そしてもうひとつは t シャツを切って
編み込んで作ったミニミニぞうり
ボタンみたいでかわいいでしょ
さて今日は
9割破壊された街が楽しいと思える理由と
いう話をしたいと思います
9割が破壊された街
そう言って床と思われると思うんです
これは長打赤く指令していますが宮城県の
女川町
今私が住んでいる街です
先代よりも北にあって石巻の隣にある
小さな町です
2011年3月に発生した
東日本大震災では震源地から一番近い町
そして人口の1割が亡くなったり行方不明
そして建物の89.2%およそ9割が破壊
された街です
そして現在人口は1万人を超えていたもの
が7千人を聞いました
被災3県の中で何かとワーストワンという
ことが多い街でもあります
今ここで私は被災地と北海道つなげる活動
をやっています
そうするとああ
故郷だからがんばっているんだねーと
勘違いされます
私は子供の頃に1回しか行ったことがない
街なので
行った時も未知の世界でした
なぜそこの女川町を選んだのか
それはある言葉との出会いからでした
何もなくなったからなんでもできるねー
なにしようかねぇ
この言葉がとっても魔法のように聞こえた
んです
これは地元の小学生から80のおじい
ちゃんおばあちゃんまでが合言葉のように
して口ずさむ言葉なんです
ここの街は元に戻すんではなくて
生まれ変わるんだ私にはそう見えました
なんかここの街には何かがある
面白い
入ってみたいそう思いました
そしてもう一つ
支援をスムーズにするためには間に立つ
人間が必要ということを感じたからです
私が被災地に入ったのは悪臭等害虫を駆除
するための作業です
女川に入る前日でした別の街での出来事
です
害獣駆除というのはとっても
重要が高かったので
役所とタッグを組んでやる予定だったん
です
それが連絡のミスマッチで何も用意されて
いない
おまけに職員の方は開き直ってしまう
あまりにも心ない言葉に私は折れそうに
なりました
でもその時にちょっと思ったんです
あれこれって
私たちだけのこんな対応を受けているはず
ないわよね
でもこのままじゃ支援がなくなっちゃう
そうもうと同時に何かが欠けてるんだなっ
て
引っかかったんです
そして作業している中でなんだろななん
だろうなって考えている中で気付いたのが
間に立つ人間
宮城と北海道の間に立つ人間がいれば
ちっちゃなことも大きな問題にならなくて
済む
支援のが支援の輪というのは広がっていく
はずだと感じたのです
そこで私が
間に立つということで初めて行ったのが
北海道で女川の消費を得ることでした
なんでそんないけないと思うと思うんです
が
まずは女川のことを知ってもらいたいなぁ
と思ったんです
女川って聞いて今でこそ被災地だって
イメージありますけれども皆女川女の
変わって女川なんですけれども
北海道でほとんどの方が目変わって呼ぶん
でしょ
または mw 呼ぶんでしょうって4です
たぶんきっとこれはあのねまんべつちょう
の女というイメージがそれからだと思い
ます
そういう意識を変えたい
そして
他の地域よりも北海道は被災地への意識を
意識の低下が早かったんですよ
被災者にとって何が一番怖いって言ったら
津波と彼自身ももちろん怖いんですそれ
以上に強いのが自分たちの存在を忘れられ
てしまうということなんです
あなたたちはもういないのよ
あなたたちにあったこと私たちは何も知ら
ないのふーんって言われるのが一番強くて
悲しいことなんです
それを防ぐためにどうしようか
あったら人間にとって一番欠かせない職
から伝えていこう
その時女川町で復興していたお土産という
のは3万を練り込んで作ったか林道でした
とても男子んです
ですが
これにかけようと思いました
なんでかっていうと震災前女川町は
本書でも有数のサンマの水揚げを誇る街
だったんですね
だから3万
でも最初からうまくいったわけではあり
ません
今でこそ本当に
3お客さん寄ってってください
尾長の女ものを持ってきたから食べてて
いけない
って思で言えるんです
たぶんこのホールの奥にいる人にも届く村
言えると思うんです
でもそれまであと二販売とかやったこと
ないんです
もう震えて震えてダメでしたっっ声が出
なくって
どうしようマイク持参しようかせる
でもそういう場所に立つことさえも嫌でし
た
そういう時に
せっかく呼んでいたイベントでももう逃げ
たいな
場違いだからどうしようそればっかり考え
てた
でもある時こんな対処方法を考えたんです
それは私自分自身の中の頭の中にもう一人
の自分を作るっていうことなんです
これは例えば恥ずかしいどうしようどう
しようどうしようっていうグズグズ言う
自分
そして
いやせっかくのチャンスな似合ってるの
恥ずかしいのと売れないのとどうなのよを
流してもらうチャンスでしょという勝気な
私の戦いなんです
それを頭の中で何度も繰り返すことで
穏やかになっていく
結果として
を長いにとってチャンスなんだから
恥ずかしいのは我慢してがんばるって自分
で思うんです
こういうことって
あの他の時にも使えて例えば自分にとって
冷静さを失ったときそれとはハァー行動
修道症って迷った時
そういう時にもう一人の自分級の作って
私はこれまで乗り越えてきました
とっても役立つんですいないと
そしてそのときに自分の立場が何であるか
本当は自分はどうしたいのかっていうこと
も頭の中で復唱するんです
私の判断基準は女川のためになるかなら
ないかということ
だからとっても大胆なるときあるんです
いやーいつもの自分だったらできない
ちょっとちょっとちょっとっていうくらい
図々しくなる私もいます
それで失敗することもあるんです
でも女川のためと軸を決めているので後
から後悔することはないです
さぁ次に行こ
切り替わるんです
間に立って行う
いろいろあります
企業間
例えば北海道の企業と尾長の木にをつなげ
て千葉3 p を
広める新商品を作るそして地域の人々同士
をつなげる
実は私早坂久美子という名前
同姓同名の方との出会いで滝川と女川の
出会いが繋がったんですそれが紙袋ラン
ターンというものです
人生の中でなかなか無いなぁと思うことな
んですけれどもこの紙袋ランターンって
いうのは紙袋
にいろいろな模様を切り込んで
本場の滝川ではまふうに行われます
中に雪を入れてろうそくをともして楽しむ
もの
でも女川ってほとんど雪が積もらないん
ですだから女川ではどうしようかなって
思った時に木片を重しにしてロウソク
代わりにライトを灯してか去ったんです
するとああ切れ等ね私も作ってみたいわと
ちっちゃい子供たちから80代後半のお
ばあさんまで
今は夢中になって作家さんとして作ってい
ます
そういった交流を繋げるのも
間に立ってつながるつなげるということだ
と思います
そして
北海道ではその真冬だけのイベントが女川
では一年中楽しめるものになりました
夜道の灯りというのは本当ないんです
だからその子供たちが高校生が駅から帰っ
てくる
仮設住宅までの道のりに灯す商店街に灯す
そして災害復興住宅にともす
今にと今ではを長いにとってとてもなくて
はならないものとなっています
そしてもう一つ
こちら見てください木の椅子です
これは北海道の東川町とのつながりから
できたものです
輝く希
の椅子と書いて希望の椅子と呼びます
多分あってご存知だ
ああ知ってるよっていう方もいらっしゃる
と思います
そ北海道では君の椅子プロジェクトとして
なじみがあると思うんです
これがどうして尾長にあってきたか
えっ時みなすプロジェクトっていうのは
もともと東川町で子供が生まれた
喜びとかおまち全体で分かち合おうよ
子どもの成長をみんなでに守ろうよって
いうことで生まれたものです
それは
尾長でも受け継ぎたいなと思っていますで
2006年に始まった東か東川場で始まっ
た君の椅子プロジェクト
震災の当日
岩手宮城福島3県では104人の子供たち
が生まれました
子どもたちにもこの子たちにも届けられて
います
いやーこんな素敵な言葉をながでもしたい
ね
そして東家の協力を得て昨年の4月から
女川町でもプロジェクトとしてスタートし
ました
そして5月30日現在
32人女川で生まれた新たな命の子たちに
届けられています
でも実はこれはもうひとつの顔があります
あるとき街の交流館でおばあさんにあった
んです
全然街並みが変わっちゃって
山も木もどんどん削られて生きるためだっ
て言われてもね悲しいんだあって
目にいっぱい涙を溜めて私に話しかけてき
たんです
そのときに私実はねっ
その杉木この杉の木は切られたヴァイス
愛された杉の木からできたものです
だから
その杉の木はねっ
こういうふうにキボン希望の椅子として
生まれ変わっているんだよと伝えました
そうするとおばあさんの彼はパッと明るく
なって良かった近所に赤ちゃんが生まれた
んだ
右かないとねっ
笑顔で帰って行かれたんです
女川ではもともと
思い出が契約風景を形そして残そうという
ことでこの希望の椅子が造られました伐採
されるスギの木で作られました
でも作ってみたら人々の心の支えに一番
なっているものというひとつになりました
色々なことが女川に入ってよね順風満帆で
あったということは言えません
私はやっぱり外ものなんです
だから地域の人と近くなれば近くなるほど
嫌がられるんですね
でも逆に大切されることもあります
そのきっかけは浜のお父ちゃんと
お母ちゃんとの出会いです
この人たちの存在が今の私に
私を作ってくれています
夕方になると必ず電話かメールかくるん
です
もしもし早坂ですって言うと
今日夕飯どこで食べるの
まだ決めてないんだけど仕事中だから
で家で食べなさい
あ
また別な日になります
はいもしも千早坂です
今日どこでご飯食べるのサー
8まるまる産地デー
えっ
明日は
まだ決まってないよ
じゃ家で食べなさい
ということで私はほとんど夕食を1人で家
で食べたことないんです
すると
きぼうのかね商店街というのが女川に復興
商店街としてあります
そこに私よく行くんですね
時間もなんか関係なくプラプラしてても
楽しい商店街なんですで歩いているとあっ
阪大ロゴに飯田
タッパーに置かずいるだから持ってないん
持って行きなさい
そしていただきますするとこれが朝ごはん
になるんです
この浜のお父ちゃんとお母ちゃんとの
つながりは
ただ何気ない会話のなかでいま何が女川で
問題になっているかということを気付かさ
れるチャンスでもあります
そして私が次に何をしたいか何ができるか
ではなく何がしたいかということを考える
きっかけを与えてくれます
私ですねこういう独特浜の父ちゃんと
母ちゃんとのつながりというのはなかなか
難しいんですけれどもこれほ
東北の独特の習慣を生かしてますそれがお
じゃっ好みです
おじゃっ好みっていうのははいこんにちは
って入って言って大概の上で漬物煮物
おかしい t をしているので
お茶を飲みに行く世間話をしに行く暇な
ときはおじいちゃんばあちゃん1日で34
件フーってもあります
いつでも来てもいいようによしてあるん
です
そういうようなことを私は女川女川にて何
も知らないですから
情報収集のためそして地域の風土を知る
ために
避難所時代から行ってきました
すると1日で1日でなんですけどもなら
このシュークリームいただいたことがある
んですね
某コンビニで新製品
某菓子屋さんで新製品
支援でいただいたからあなたがくるって
いうからとっておいたの
逆光きつかったんです
おかげで女川に入って14キロも増えまし
たん
戻らないです
でもその母さんタッチとの関係はとても
大事
そしてポイントはその関係性を縮めるのに
は
5つのポイントがあるんです
まず笑顔で近づくこと
何にも知らないから教えてねと頼ること
共通点を見いだすこと
そしてひたすら聞き役に回ること
で最も重要なのがたまにケンカをすること
です
お客さんとは絶対しないことですよ
近くになるからこそ
半田原たず
って言われても
怒られても次の日には昨日ごめんねーって
言って仲直りになるんです
浜の母さんたち
が私を家族だと言ってくれる
そういうことがあるから
頑張れるんですね
たまに困る時もあるんです
浜の母さんた中は私を娘という時があるん
ですねそれも気づきました最近
それは悪いことではないんですけれども
ただちょっと困るんです
ただ困るというか悪いことではないんです
けれどもただ他の人に私を紹介する時に
うちの娘7年度な子だけどなんとか
育て上げましたで皿って言うんですね
それを他に支援に来た東京からだ福岡から
でいろんな支援の人が来てくださいます
その時に疑問に思うんですよね
何か良い至る所で早坂さんを盗めって言う
人がいるんですけれども本当のお母さんっ
てどんな人ですか
だから私きっぱり言うんですね
私に北海道の人間なの血のつながりも
なければ嫁でもないのよ
と言うと
皆さんに衝撃が走るみたいなんですね
そういった方達を守っていきたい
家族を守っていきたいと思ったら
この街がどんな状態にあっても面白いと
感じることがあると思います
9割が9割破壊された街が楽しいと思える
理由
そのポイントはさきほども言いましたが何
もなくなったからなんでもできるねって
いう発想
そしてそこには町民が思っている意識の
転換
その
たからというのが
発想の転換をするそしてそれが実際に動き
出しているというのが女川の強みであり
ハマーの父さん母さんの家族いろいろな方
が来た時に家族として
対応できるものがあるからだと思います
拙い話でしたがご静聴ありがとうござい
ました